his light were put in contemplating an
all-out invasion of Ukraine he might but
he also has other options and the West
should be prepared to respond to each of
them the first two weeks of April
Vladmir Putin ordered Russian commanders
into half a dozen of Ukrainian cities
and towns they seized administrative and
police buildings there why did he do it
he may have several options in mind one
option before Putin is to freeze the
situation at the current status quo
without increasing the presence or
visibility of the Russian troops in east
and southern Ukraine and then use the
situation described by Moscow as a chaos
lack of authority and lack of
sovereignty by the Ukrainian government
in eastern and southern parts of Ukraine
as a negotiating leverage in its talks
with Ukraine but primarily United States
and EU Russia would then insist on
federalization of Ukraine which in
effect means that southern and eastern
parts of that country will become
Russia's defective protectorates a
second option is the escalation of the
Russian military presence in east and
southern Ukraine provoking the Ukrainian
government finally to respond with force
and almost inevitably leading to
violence bloodshed and death that's
bringing southern and eastern Ukraine
essentially to the point of a continuous
armed conflict one of lineman Putin's
favorite propaganda tricks is to use
Western policies as precedents to
justify Moscow's actions he could point
out to the Western involvement in Libya
to protect civilians during a civil war
as a pretext for an all-out Russian
invasion ostensibly to protect the
ethnic Russians and the russian-speaking
Ukrainians in that part of the country
whatever options Vladimir Putin may
consider there is a deadline to them on
May twenty-fifth the Ukrainians will
choose a new president in what is likely
to be free and fair election certified
by international observers after that it
will be exceedingly difficult for
Vladimir Putin to claim that Ukraine
does not have a legitimate government
and therefore requires intervention by
Russia to protect the civilian
population in east and south but it is
also a deadline for the West it is
impossible to dislodge Putin from Crimea
or southern and eastern Ukraine at this
point instead the policy should be aimed
at his domestic political base which
will begin to feel the pinch of economic
hardships if truly biting economic
sanctions are imposed